This episode is sponsored by ground news. Judge, the truth for yourself.
Round.
News is the world's first news comparison platform.
It will let you see how various media have processed information and alert you
to their political point of view.
This allows you to have a better awareness of what you are reading via a
political spectrum at all.
See the news you're not seeing ground news is geographic filters.
Let you search everything from hyper local news to global events and with all
the information coming out about the current events with the police and the
protestors in the U S you'll be able to find accurate statistics and reliable
facts. News changes quickly and cycles are shorter than ever,
but at ground news,
you can keep track of all the threats concerning your topics of interest,
refresh your memory on stories, or just observe the ways news spirals out.
You can also audit your own news. Yes, that's right.
They give you a simple view of who has covered a story and where each outlet
falls on the political spectrum.
You can get the ground news app for free in both the Apple app store and the
Google play store.
Click the link in the description below and try ground to news for free.
Now let's get into today's video.
[Inaudible].
America has a problem protests over George Floyd's death are the last straw.
And this video we're going to put the racial issue aside and focus on a much
more specific problem. Police brutality.
Think about it more than 1000 people.
Died at the hands of the police every year in the United States. Of course,
this number can be much higher in other countries. For example,
Venezuelan police killed more than 5,500 people in 2018, but let's be honest,
having these things happen in Venezuela,
given its recent political and economic problems is hardly surprising where the
United States is. The world's greatest power,
even worse is the fact that the United States has the highest crime rates in the
developed world. In other words, police in the USA,
I'm not doing their job well, and this is a more serious problem than it's.
Seems.
The state is an institution that offers services in exchange for our taxes of
all the services. The most important is security.
It doesn't matter if we're talking about a system that's socialist capitalist or
an absolute monarchy.
We all agree that the main function of the state is to provide security for
citizens. In this sense, United States leaves much to be desired.
Make some comparisons.
Anyone who lives in Europe can walk down the street without being afraid of
cops. Yet crime rates are much lower than in the USA in a country,
such as Spain or the Czech Republic.
The murder rate is 0.6 homicides per 100,000 inhabitants in the
United States. It is 4.958 times higher.
If someone were able to solve this one problem right now,
it would be enough to really make America great again.
And we're talking about something that interests both Democrats and Republicans.
But that's an old surprising.
As it may seem. This is a problem that have a solution.
There is no need to reinvent the wheel here,
just copied what other countries have already done.
And we have an example that could provide many ideas to the U S politicians.
Yes.
Official politic the Spanish police have much to contribute to the world.
To give you an idea.
Spain has one of the lowest crime rates in the world and how many people died at
the hands of the police last year? Zero, absolutely zero. In fact,
this is not the first time the Spanish police have been used as an example for
other countries.
A new civil guard,
contingent to parts for Afghanistan to train police in Herat and Kaboom.
The question is how can the U S solve its problem with the police?
What could Spain contribute to that solution today?
We're going to answer these questions, but first let's look at some history.
The police army.
You may be surprised, but 6% of the us population are war veterans.
That's right.
We're talking about people that have been fighting at the front and who's
returned to civilian. Life often comes with a lot of truffles.
Many of them suffer from post-traumatic stress disorder,
which is a real nightmare that many cannot escape from others are unable to find
a job. And at the end of the day,
the skills they have learned on the front line are of little use in civilian
life. It's a fact, the us owes a huge debt to its veterans. And in many cases,
it's not able to repay it.
This explains the government's programs to help integrate these veterans.
One of them is the police that's right for decades. All governments,
both local and federal have prioritized war veterans when hiring new cops and
the result today,
one in five police officers in the United States is a war veteran.
And you're probably thinking where's the problem.
After all a former soldier seems to be the right person to be a cop, right?
He or she knows how to use a weapon,
how to work as a team and how to deal with high stress situations. And yes,
you will be right there.
Well,
the problem is that there are more than 18,000 different police forces in the
United States and each one works completely independently.
And this set up becomes a really serious problem.
When we talk about the war on drugs until the 1970s,
most of the criminals encountered by the police were petty thieves,
armed with guns and knives,
but everything changed in the 1980s with the advent of the big drug cartel.
Yes.
Suddenly criminals were using top-notch weapons, assault, rifles,
Uzi machine guns, and even grenade launches.
So what was the outcome that the police had to update their weapons in order to
stand a chance against this new threat, consider this so far,
we've talked about the numbers of murders committed by the police,
but we should also talk about the number of cops killed in the us
between 2020 14 alone.
More than 2,400 policemen were killed by criminals who increasingly
better trained. Think about it for a minute.
We're talking about a country where it's incredibly easy to get a firearm at
this, to the arrival of well-organized gangs.
And you have the ideal cocktail for an ultra violent society.
In circumstances like this, you need a police officer who is up to it.
And so in 1981, the United States Congress passed.
This law.
Let's read cooperation with civilian law enforcement agencies act as a United
States.
Federal law enacted in 1981 that allows the United States armed forces to
cooperate with domestic and foreign law enforcement agencies.
Words. This law allowed all Pentagon weaponry.
That was no longer being used in conflicts to be reused by the police.
Think about it more and more war veterans are working as cops,
and they're also using the same weapons they used on the war front of the
problem.
The problem is that the streets of Baghdad have nothing to do with the streets
of Kansas city.
A wartime soldier needs totally different training than a cop who has to work
together with his own neighbors.
And the question is to what extent do us cops get the training?
They need.
Selves to be a cop in Texas.
You need to spend about four months at the police Academy to be a policeman in
Finland. You need to do a two year master's degree and Norway.
We're talking about three years training and in Spain,
it's between nine months and one year. In other words,
over the past few decades,
nearly all of those 18,000 us police forces have assumed that all war veterans
were more than prepared to be a cop of just a few weeks of class.
And as you can imagine, it's not enough, but hold on a minute because that,
isn't the only problem.
If you thought that the purpose of this video is to criticize the us army. Well,
you're very, very wrong. Actually,
there is a very big difference between the army and the police and the
differences. This.
Us military personnel have been convicted of $5 million worth of cranes.
Oddly enough, this is good news. It means there's justice in the U S military.
If you do wrong, you pay the price.
And this is explained by the fact that the U S military has a long tradition of
respect for institutions. If a soldier commits a crime,
no one's going to defend it.
This explains why soldiers who tortured prisoners of war in Abu Ghraib prison
were immediately tried for example. And you'll probably be wondering,
so what about the police?
Are there any laws governing the police in the U S well, I'll let you.
Yourselves.
For Chicago police officers fired and an alleged cover-up for Jason van.
This is just one example of what we've been able to find out about.
No matter what report you read,
no one doubts that many police officers cover for their colleagues,
regardless of whether they were in the rights or wrong.
All of this helps explain why in recent years,
us police have killed more than 7,600 citizens,
but only 48 policemen have actually been convicted.
And the rest haven't even met.
It's a trial.
For this qualitative immunity and trade unions. You see, unlike the military,
the police in the United States can join a trade union and police unions have
enormous power in that country, especially this one, the order of police,
they have more than 340,000 members and are a pressure group with a lot of
influence in Washington. It's influence explains news headlines.
Yes.
We screw up director. Obama caused a war on cops. Exactly.
Every time a politician has tried to reform the police in the United States,
they have clashed with the refusal of police unions and all of this puts the
murder of George Floyd into clear context.
The cop who killed him knew it was almost impossible for him to go to jail for
something like that. At the end of the day, who was going to judge him,
judicial doctrines are in his favor and the other policemen are going to defend
him.
And the political institutions are not going to raise their voices for fear of
reprisals from trade unions. And you'll say,
does the white house really not dare regulate the police for fear.
Bunions?
Well, the truth is that all kinds of programs have tried to solve this problem.
In the past, for example, during the Obama administration,
the innovative police program was approved. Its intentions were fantastic.
Train the cops to learn how to use physical force proportionately, the problem,
the execution in the end,
all those good intentions resulted in well visits to museums of African-American
history and days of debate among policemen to discuss the problems of race in
the United States.
And I think you can probably imagine how effective these programs have been.
And you're probably wondering,
is there any way to improve the police in the USA? Well, the truth is yes.
Let's take a look right now.
What spin can. Sure. The United States by now,
I'm sure you've all seen the video of George Floyd's murder.
And if you haven't seen it well, you can find it on any social network.
We are not going to include the footage here. As a matter of respect,
the truth is what the cop does in the video is not anything that police don't do
in any other country. It's, what's called a ni restraint.
That is the pop immobilizes, the criminal by placing his knee.
Oh, I don't know if [inaudible].
What's the problem. As we always say here, or visual politic,
the devil is in the details. The copy in this video, places,
the knee over Floyd's neck, instead of his back in addition,
the knee restraint is a maneuver that lasts between one and two minutes.
The time needed to be able to handcuff the suspect for transport to the police
station. I mean, in this case,
we'd be talking about negligent practice in the very least.
So the question is what would have happened if the death of George Floyd had
occurred in Spain instead of the United States? Well, in that case,
the policemen would have had to write a very detailed report of everything that.
What happened.
Well, the cop hadn't lied,
medical examiner could analyze the body to find out why the victim died.
And this report would be grounds for George Floyd's family to report the Spanish
policemen.
And chances are that the cop would end up sentenced to several years in prison.
According to the Spanish legal system, this crime is a torture.
This isn't something I just made up.
The truth is that there have been very similar cases. Look at this.
Spain for several guards convicted.
Of torturing members of the terrorist group atta.
And I know what many of you will be thinking, Josh, that's a lie.
Spain has a lot of convictions from the human rights court in Strasburg for
police brutality vans. Yes, you're right.
There are many cases of alleged police brutality in Spain for a start amnesty
international has denounced several human rights violations during protests,
by Catalan independence. The question is what happens in other countries.
And the truth is that Spain does not have many more combinations than other
European countries, such as France or Germany. In other words, in every country,
there are bad cops, but if we compare Spain to the rest of the world,
we discover a police force that stands out for being particularly novel.
This is truly surprising when you take into account the history of Spain,
for those of you who don't know until 1975,
Spain was under the thumb of a military dictatorship,
like all military dictators,
general Francisco Franco was not concerned with human rights for decades.
The Spaniards suffered unthinkable levels of police repression worse than in any
other European country. But everything changed in 1986,
the year in which this law passed.
Ganache law two forward slash one nine, eight, six,
March 13th on the security forces and bodies.
So what is this law all about?
Basically this law introduced a concept never seen before in Spain,
gradual violence,
but another way we all understand that the police may need to use violence at
some point, unfortunately, many criminals don't listen to reason for that.
The police need to use some force. This is a fact.
Now there is violence and violence,
and this is how the principle that the Spanish police has been guided by since
the eighties opportunity, congruence,
proportionality at least possible force was born.
That means a Spanish police officer can't hit you unless there is any indication
that you might hit him.
A Spanish cop can't pull out his gun unless there is clear evidence.
[Inaudible].
In particular,
there is a very specific principle called the operational intervention system.
It consists of the following before using force,
a policeman has to give you a verbal warning, tell you something like,
please get out of the car. We have to search you.
The next level is hand to hand combat.
If the suspect in question shows signs of being armed,
the policemen may move on to the next level of force.
So-called percussion techniques, battens, extendable bars, or electric tasers.
Finally, as a last resort, if the situation continues to escalate,
the policeman can then use a firearm.
All these principles are taught at the Spanish police Academy for nine months in
that course, techniques are taught as self-defense.
That knee restraint is practiced many times, but it doesn't end here.
[Inaudible].
Example within the Spanish police,
there is a body called the civil guard and this body has its own training
program. Check it out.
The patio operational intervention plan, and the civil guard is implemented.
This patio program consists of continuous training for all civil guards.
Every six months, they are required to do special two day courses.
These courses have exercises to improve police techniques.
Things like searching or knee restraints are tested for hours.
This has nothing in common with the visits to museums like they're doing in
America. To give you an idea. The obsession with police training in Spain,
reaches extremes.
This
the interior ministry will provide police and civil guards with almost 1,200
tasers.
Order to use those 1,200 electric guns.
So-called tasers cops are required to take a special clearance course.
That is until they learn how to use a new weapon. They can't use it.
What's more,
I'm going to share with you a very curious detail in those courses where using
tasers are taught.
It is very normal for cops to experience it on their own flesh. I mean,
they grab a cop between two people and shoot him with a taser shot to see how it
hurts. And I know what a lot of people will be thinking,
especially those who are watching this video from the United States.
Is it really possible to import these policies into the U S police?
Well.
There's a small detail. Unlike the United States in Spain,
police unions have very little power. Moreover,
some law enforcement agencies like the civil guard are prohibited from joining
any union.
All this has allowed reforms to be implemented almost without any problems.
It is very likely that in the United States,
such a move to reform would be much more complicated.
The advantage is that the United States is on the threshold of an election and
protests over the assassination of George Floyd are a very good opportunity to
incorporate the issues of police brutality and appropriate training into the
political debate.
So now the question is over to you.
Do you think the U S Cambra form it's police,
to what extent can you repeat in countries be a model?
How could this country improve? If it could fix one of its worst problems,
you can leave me your answer in the comments as always,
don't forget that we upload new videos every week.
So subscribe to visual policy and make sure that you don't miss any of our
updates, a big thanks to ground news,
the app that helps you see where your news is coming from.
Check out the free ground news app by following the link down below.
If you liked this video, give it a like, and I'll see you in the next one.
Take care.
Yeah.